is it okay to do everything yourself as
an entrepreneur I'm going to answer that
question in today's episode of the
basket so got a question from one of my
youtube viewers love you guys
pushing pixels who wrote in to say it's
always interesting taking these kinds of
videos and mentally converting them to
how they would apply to someone like
myself trying to make a business out of
my youtube channel so many entrepreneurs
always talk about removing yourself from
the mechanisms of the business as much
as possible but for me the passion comes
from that low level work not just the
effect and impact that work will have on
people and the vision behind it all
would you suggest anything differently
if someone is working on a one-person
business like a YouTube channel where
your face is just as much as a product
as your words I mean you run the channel
so you must have some thoughts pushing
pixels I do have some thoughts I'm gonna
share with you my three tips to help me
solve this problem so number one is
identify what you love you've got to do
what you love if you want to have
success in whatever you're doing in your
life and in your business and within
your business right now you want to
figure out what is it that your local
where's your passion if that is being in
front of the camera that's great if that
is being behind the scenes and editing
that's great that's where you're gonna
pour your love into it right oh I was
watching example of kisi nice that who
has a huge channel on YouTube in every
video that he puts out has hundreds of
thousands or millions of views and he
still edits everything himself he's the
face but he does all the editing himself
on his videos and they'll stay up till
2:00 3:00 4:00 in the morning editing
his blog because he loves it because
that's where his passion is because he
doesn't want to give over the editing to
somebody else and so that has led him to
build a massively successful business
but also a great YouTube channel
she's got identified
that you love and how can you spend more
time doing that and if that's doing the
back end stop the things you consider
low-level times then do that because
you're gonna perform those tasks in a
much more creative way in a much more
amazing way in a much more high-value
way than anybody else because you love
it
number two is determine how much do you
want to grow some businesses so much
printers they don't want to grow they
want a one-person show they don't want
to have a team they don't want to do
anything big they're happy with what
they're doing they're making their
whatever it is per month and that's a
good life for them they want the
work-life balance and that's it they
don't want to grow any more and so if
that's you then stick with it you can do
it within yourself you never have to
grow and you can be a happy camper if
you want more if you want to make more
money if you want to have a bigger
impact if you want to make sure you have
a team then you'll have to go back to
figure out again what it is that you
love doing and helping you then those
take those other pieces and give them
away but it comes from your ambition is
your ambition bit do you want to do
something big if you do that you can't
do it alone right you look at people
who've gone on to do huge things it's
never alone there's always a team it may
start off as one person but it always
builds to be a team and so how big do
you want to take your company and number
three is eliminate automate delegate now
do you know what you love doing or what
you don't love doing and if you want to
build a team up then you eliminate the
stuff you can eliminate you automate the
stuff can be automated and then you
delegate the rest and ideally you are
focusing your time the things that you
love doing that are high value on and
not doing the stuff that you don't love
doing anymore and that's that happens
for everybody right there are things in
your business that you don't love doing
and for you to be highly successful it's
not going to come from doing the things
that you don't love doing give that to
somebody that loves doing it and and so
that's that's the secret that's the key
is getting that team around you in my
business I started doing my YouTube
channel all myself
I filmed myself I edited myself I posted
to YouTube myself and as I got into what
is a final challenge learning how to
edit videos but then it got boring for
me and it wasn't the best use of my time
or skill that most importantly I wasn't
passionate about it is you can learn
something if you're passionate about it
I didn't want to learn it my passion was
been in front of the camera and talking
to you guys and so I went from doing one
video a week where I was editing
everything myself and posting YouTube
myself to now making 13 14 videos a week
where all I have to do is stay in front
of the camera and press record and my
video editor Christina does everything
else for me and so I'm able to have a
much bigger impact I'm Way happier I'm
getting much more traction and making a
lot more money because I'm doing what I
love and so if you find what you love
and focus on that and eliminate automate
delegate the rest of it you'll have a
lot more success believe it was your
watching I'd love to know your thoughts
on is it okay that stays a one-person
shop and your strategies on how to do it
tell me what your goals are leave it in
the comments below I'm gonna join in the
discussion and I look forward to hearing
from you thank you so much for watching
I'll see you soon